everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve
jump game two so you might remember
recently we solved the first jump game
problem and i would recommend watching
that video or solving that problem
yourself before looking at this one
because this one is actually
very similar the main difference is we
are the premise of the problem is the
exact same we're given
an integer array of non-negative
integers
they're always non-negative and we are
placed at the
first index of this array so let's say
this is our input array
we're going to be placed at the first
index over here and
our goal is going to be over here the
last value in the index that's the goal
and our goal is to jump to
the last position from the first
position in
our integer right in this problem though
the question we're trying to answer is
what is the
minimum number of jumps that it takes
for us to reach
the last index and luckily for us we can
always
assume that we're always going to be
able to reach that last index
so in this first problem we know that
we're starting here right in this two
position
if we take so since we're at the
position two we have two choices right
we can either take a jump of
length one or we can take a jump of
length
two our choices are these two values
the three and the one if we take if we
reach
the one then we take one more jump
get to the second one and then we take a
third jump to get to the four
which is the goal right the goal is the
four
the last position of the array or if we
if we go to the 3 instead then we
actually just take a jump
of length 3 to get to the 4 which means
that in this case it'll take us exactly
two jumps right we go from two to three
and then we get to the goal so that took
two steps
two jumps and our output can be two
because we're looking for
that minimum number of steps
so you might know that this is a problem
that can be
solved with dynamic programming just
like the first jump game solution
but i'm not really going to go over the
dynamic programming solution because
actually just
like jump game one this problem also has
a greedy solution
and it turns out that the greedy
solution is a linear time
solution so oh big o of n whereas
the dynamic programming solution is
actually big
o of n squared so we know that with this
problem we can make a some kind of
decision tree right we know that
this first position right two it has
two choices right if we're jumping from
this position right we can jump to the
three
or we can jump to the one right
so those are our decisions right so
really from two we can get to these
next two values the greedy solution
is going to be something similar to
a breath first search type solution
right
so next so we looked at this value right
this
two that was the starting position and
we saw that these
are the next values that we can go to
from there right
we're going to continue this process
that's why it's kind of like a breath
first search
because we're going to be continuing
this exact algorithm what we're going to
be doing though
now is we saw that from here we could
get to these next
two values now the next question becomes
from this entire portion of the array
what are all the other values outside of
this portion that we can also reach
let's take a look at that from this
three we know we can reach
this next one right but that doesn't
count because it's already a part of our
green
area right we can reach that one but
it's redundant because we can already
get to this part we can also get to this
next one right so that's going to be at
the next
level or the next part of our breadth
first search
we can also reach the destination which
is four right at this point we would we
would normally be done with our
algorithm because we know that
we can reach this four and we've
basically found the minimum number of
steps that
allow us to do that but we're going to
continue with this just
to understand the algorithm so we know
that from this 3
we are able to reach these two values
let's just continue it just to see okay
this one
we also need to check what are all the
positions it can reach well in this case
it can only reach this one and that's
already included in our purple area
okay so now we see that that this purple
level
is what we can reach from the green
level these
portions and the whole reason i'm color
coding this is because the levels
tell us how many steps it takes to reach
these
cells the minimum number of steps right
we know that we
start at this position right therefore
the number of steps it takes to reach
this position is zero right
it takes zero jumps for us to reach this
position
how now my question to you is how many
steps does how many
jumps does it take to reach the green
uh values it takes exactly
one jump right that's the whole point of
color coding it because we know from
two we can jump here or we can jump here
it takes
one jump for us to reach any of these
values if we're taking the minimum route
right we're taking the minimum number of
jumps
now next what about the purple
values how many jumps what's the minimum
number of jumps that it takes
for us to reach these well obviously
it's two
because if it takes us one jump to reach
these green values
and we can take one jump from the green
to get to the purple
it's going to take one extra jump to get
here so it's obviously going to be
two jumps right this is pretty simple
this is a pretty straightforward
algorithm we would continue it
if we had more values in our array
but as you can see what we're doing here
is basically
through a simple or a one-dimensional
array
breadth-first search we are finding the
minimum
path or the minimum number of jumps to
reach the destination right remember we
only care about the destination once we
reach the destination
we are done so in this case we can see
it takes exactly
two jumps for us to reach the
destination
so this is the visual explanation
but now hopefully you get the idea of
what we're doing the colors hopefully
can illustrate that and we're going to
translate this into the code it's
very little code the code is actually
pretty straightforward
let me show you how to do that part now
that we know the breadth for search
algorithm
so remember we are counting the number
of jumps it takes to reach the
destination we'll call that result we'll
initially set that to zero i'm also
going to have two pointers
left and right and they're both
initially going to be set to
zero because these left and right
pointers are going to tell us our
window we saw that initially the window
starts at just 0 0 right the first
initial value so that's what it's going
to be
we know that i think the second level
was
where left equals 1 right equals
2 right so this would represent a window
from
index 1 all the way to index 2 and
that's basically this is basically going
to determine what level of
or what portion of the array is going to
be used for breadth first search
currently
and we know we are going to continue
this algorithm until
right which is the rightmost value of
our current portion
until it reaches the last value of
the input array so while our right
pointer is
less than the last index we're going to
be continuing our algorithm and keep
incrementing that result so just for
visual purposes
uh what i mean by the left pointer is
that let's say we're currently going
through the green our left pointer would
be here because it's the left
most value of the portion we're going
through our right pointer would be at
the rightmost portion
so that's great last thing is how are we
gonna determine the boundaries for the
next portion well what we're gonna do is
we're gonna look at
who can jump the farthest the three the
farthest jump it can make
is one two three right the farthest jump
it can make is to this
value the one the farthest jump it can
do is just a one so it can get here
right
so what we're going to do now to update
our pointers is
we're going to take our left pointer and
set it to
right plus one right it's gonna be
adjacent to the
right pointer so this is where our left
pointer would go
where's our right pointer gonna go it's
gonna go
to the place that we can jump the
farthest right it's going to go to the
right boundary of
our purple area so we're going to cross
this out
and put right over here the reason we're
putting it over here
is that's the farthest position that we
can jump to from the
previous section the green section
so now let's get back into the code so
we are going to have a
variable farthest which is going to tell
us who can jump the farthest and what's
the index of that jump
so right now we're going to go through
our portion you could say we're going
through
our green portion so for i in range
uh from left to right plus one because
we have to make
the right value inclusive so going
through this loop all we're trying to
determine is who can jump the farthest
because that's going to determine how we
can update our left and right pointers
so
what we're going to do is just set
farthest equal
to the max of itself and the max
of the jump that we're currently
performing so i
is the index that tells us the jump
we're performing so we're jumping
from index i so i plus
the value at index i which tells us how
far we can actually
jump so nums of i plus i is going to
tell us
what's the look what's the farthest
location that this could jump to
and so we're going to take the max of
this and then update
that farthest variable by the end of it
we should be good farthest should be
set to what the farthest it can go is
and then we can update
our window right so we can say left is
now going to be equal to right
plus one just like i showed in the
picture right
is going to be equal to farthest and
don't forget to increment the result
each time because remember
that's telling us how many jumps we're
taking to get to that
end point so once you're done with this
that's actually the entire algorithm
after that all you have to do is return
the result
so what we're doing here is basically uh
a simplified
breadth first search it's we're doing it
on a one-dimensional
array and we're using a left and right
variables to keep track of what our
current window is we're also updating
that window as we keep progressing
once our window or in other words our
right pointer
reaches the last value in the input
array
that's when you know that we're done
counting the jumps and
we can stop our in our loop and then we
can return
the number of jumps that we took the
minimum number of jumps
so i hope that this was helpful i hope
you have a visual
understanding of this problem as well as
understanding the code
and thank you for watching uh don't
forget to like and subscribe if this was
helpful
and have a great day i'll see you pretty
soon